how long did it take you on the masked
singer to get into the butterfly I talk
about maybe 10 minutes to get into it it
was just one piece in the head in the
wings not long
you guys were crazy costly Destiny's
Child which is crazier and what was the
difference the masked singer was crazier
cuz it was a more hot and it was the
head with the huge antenna so I had to
walk sideways down the hallways did
Jonah I got electrocuted
what yes during dress rehearsal I'm
standing on the platform and they're
trying to have the co2 the smoke
comfortable so I'm saying so on the oh
it supposed to go baby that sang listen
all I know is I look down at my shoe and
it could talk that they do what's what's
your shoot yeah yeah you know I always
have to ask is there a chance that you
would ever ever ever get back together
with the ladies anything is possible but
you know what I really mean really do
you want to break some news right now
tell me why I wish I could and if I did
it's a possibility we would tell you all
right tell me about also listen the
white Christmas the musical you're doing
right now I'm excited to do a snow white
Christmas I play the Wicked Queen I have
never seen you be evil exes say
differently it's okay I'm just playing
well I don't know one or two might say
well I'll tell you what you need to do
you need to go see Michelle's musical it
snow white Christmas
[Music]